hey this is presto Walker a test in New
Zealand has left many 15 year olds in
tears because they felt the questions
were nearly impossible to solve this is
causing huge controversy in New Zealand
and it's even gathering the attention of
British and American news outlets in
this video I want to share one of the
problems that people feel has been very
difficult to solve and I want to go over
how I would solve this problem so I've
reproduced one of the test questions
here it comes with the following diagram
in a children's playground there is a
rope hanging from two points a and B on
a horizontal beam a and B are 6 metres
apart the lowest point of the rope is 1
meter above the ground the shape of the
rope can be modeled by the following
equation y equals x over 3 times the
quantity X minus P plus 4 where Y is the
height above the ground and X is the
distance from A this is a four part
question part one how high above the
ground is a part to give the value of P
part three on the grid sketch the graph
that models the shape of the rope and
part four it comes with a slightly
modified diagram and here's the question
holes are drilled through a two meter
long horizontal board the Rope passes
through the holes to make the seat of a
swing the height of the seat is 1.2
meters above the ground
how far apart would the holes in the
board need to be if the shape of the
rope above the seat stays the same
give your answer to two decimal places
can you figure out these problems give
them a try and when you're ready keep
watching my attempt at a solution to
this problem
so here's how I would solve the first
part how high above the ground is a
point a the distance from a is zero
which equals x substituting this value
into the equation we get y equals zero
over 3 times the quantity zero minus P
this will become zero and then we have
plus four this simplifies to be y equals
four
hence point a is four meters off the
ground
now for part two we need to give the
value of P point B is x equals 6 meters
from a furthermore point B is the same
distance off the ground as a since a is
4 meters off the ground that means B is
also 4 meters off so y equals 4 so we
have 6 comma 4 as the values for B
substituting these values into the
equation we get 4 is equal to 6 over 3
times the quantity 6 minus P plus 4 we
can then simplify this to be 0 equals 2
times the quantity 6 minus P which then
simplifies to be P equals 6 now for part
three we need to sketch the graph that
models the shape of the rope what I
would do is I know the location of
points a and B the parabola passes
through point a which is 0 4 and B which
is 6 4 furthermore by symmetry the
lowest point has an x value that's
halfway between a and b and the lowest
point is 1 feet off the ground so the
lowest point is 3 comma 1 so I would
take those three points and I would
sketch a curve between them and I would
put arrows to indicate that they
continue onward in each exit direction
now we get to the part which many people
seem to think is just impossible we have
a board that's 1.2 meters off the ground
and the question is how far with the
holes in the board need to be if the
shape of the rope stays the same we can
translate this question to mean what's
the distance between the two holes in
this board in other words what's the
distance between the two x-values when y
equals 1.2 this leads to a concrete math
problem we take our equation and we
substitute in y equals one point two we
have 1.2 equals x over 3 times the
quantity X minus 6 plus 4 we can then
subtract 1.2 from both sides and we can
expand out x over 3 times X minus 6 this
becomes 0 is equal to x squared over 3
minus 2x plus 2.8 we then multiply by 3
so that we have 0 is equal to x squared
minus 6x plus 8.4 this is just so that x
squared has a coefficient of 1 we can
now solve for the X values by using the
quadratic formula X is equal to the
opposite of B plus or minus the square
root of b squared minus 4ac all over 2a
but before we substitute in the values
we want to find the distance between
them so we can write out the two
different X values one of them will be
the positive square root and the other
will be the negative square root and we
want to find the difference between them
so I'll take the absolute value of x1
minus x2 making sure that we get the
positive distance this simplifies to be
the square root of b squared minus 4ac
all over the absolute value of a we now
take our quadratic equation where we
have a equals 1 B equals negative 6
and c is equal to 8.4 this simplifies to
be the square root of six squared minus
four times one times eight point four
all over one and therefore we get that
the distance between the two x-values is
the square root of two point four which
is approximately one point five five so
what do you think was this question
impossible for fifteen-year-olds and did
you figure it out thanks for watching
this video please subscribe to my
channel I make videos on math you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
if you like this video you can support
me on patreon you can also check out my
books which are listed in the video
description you can also catch me on
social media at mind your decisions or
at precious Harker depending on the site